this is Rwanda nestled between these
plantations village homes and meandering
mountain roads is a pasture land no
bigger than a football field from here
this guy launches drones that carry
blood to doctors racing and save their
patients lives
he's the delivery man of the future and
he's one of the first people ever to get
the job now he's waiting for the rest of
the world to catch up as technology
replaces old jobs it's also creating new
ones I'm Aki Ito and I'm here to show
you the jobs of the future
[Music]
my name is Miz Emma Abdul Salam and I'm
a drone operator Abdul works for
start-up called zip line this is where -
the drones like that's recovery system
and in front of you this is were
launched the drones zip line is
headquartered in California but it's all
the way here west of Rwanda Scapa del
Kigali that the company's launched one
of the world's first drone delivery
services so beautiful no Abdul and his
coworkers are tackling a deadly problem
here Rwanda is among the poorest
countries in the world and much of it is
connected by winding bumpy dirt roads in
the mountains that get washed out in the
rainy seasons
that's made it incredibly difficult for
regional hospitals to procure blood in
an emergency
leaving doctors unable to perform many
life-saving operations the hospital have
to procure the car you have to drive I
don't know for three or four hours to be
ollie
get the blood and then come back that's
complicated the idea is to give access
toward those people live in more areas
to the healthcare system especially to
speed motors and launch is applying one
tree tree when a hospital asked for
blood the zipline team gets moving if
it's a typical day like a normal day you
grab a package you load it in the plane
you get a plan Odie and I do for launch
slash unsecured your launch head
[Music]
and then you went for the next order
guided by GPS and other sensors the
drone flies itself to one of the
hospitals it serves then it reaches its
destination and drops off its payload
hospital staff retrieve the supplies and
the drone heads back to base and then
this happens
[Applause]
kind of like catching a fish that's just
so complicated more than that so then I
have to go up pretty fast
like and the vehicle will catch it look
at the space in between here it's tiny
really small that's an impressive level
of precision
okay now you can lift it yep
will you hire me now yeah Abdo doing
pretty well for himself these days he's
got a job he loves and he's studying for
grad school but all that success today
is built from unimaginable tragedy
when he was three the Rwandan government
stepped up its decades-long assault on
the Tutsi minority ordering everyone in
the Hutu majority to kill all Tutsis in
just a hundred days 800,000 people were
slaughtered by their neighbors and their
friends when the people were doing the
genocide showed up my father was the
first to step out look alike hear the
voice of kind in the collied old people
talking passing like where where is the
rest of where is the rest of the family
so and then they killed him and they
came in they found us was a tiny room
and then they basically hit anyone like
everyone with a machete have a small you
see that yeah yep Wow despite the head
wound
Abdullah survived his two siblings and
his parents didn't he ended up at a
homeless shelter
then his grandma found him and took him
in 1900 harvick we didn't go movie - Vic
I'm within the choir but a competitor up
Seija evil I wish a militia no seed to
multiply by get hwa-ja he said I would
rather live in peace it was hard he was
a stubborn kid at school and caused a
lot of trouble to my grandma because
sometimes I will just quit school so
definitely I think the first couple
years of school was really hard
yeah and then after that I find I found
my life again I was like okay if I get
my education right and I used the
knowledge I have to serve the community
then I'm happy with my life Abdul
studied engineering in college while
holding a variety of repair and
maintenance jobs when zip line opened
its first distribution center in rural
Rwanda he jumped at the chance to work
on cutting-edge drone technology
but his grandma was sad to see him move
out of her home in Kigali and others in
his extended family worried he was
leaving better opportunities behind in
Ronda if you dress well you go walk with
a suit and you have a big office like
your family would be very happy there
thought like you were successful even
though you may be paid way less than in
like someone who's dirty every day they
all still think that is a true
definition of being successful have you
ever worn a suit to zipline and no
eventually they all came around kasi
Acorah McKissack Arashi mich CooCoo naga
Hattori now Gurudwara to Navarro Naraku
Shema i Jesse get your cone maker makan
again I'm ahead
the spring Rwanda commemorated 24 years
since the genocide in those years the
economy's grown Sevenfold
in the bustling city markets the crowds
of giggling kids and the smiles of young
mothers in the villages you sense the
optimism everywhere
we refer to agenda to saza idoko abuh
Peru country physical Alchemist Ibaka
domain of language a guru has us from
Google the Amazon tech giants around the
world are now racing to get their drone
delivery trials off the ground it's been
exciting for Abdul to be at the
forefront of all that but what drives
him is the impact he's making closer to
home I think like I got another chance
to leave so I was like would I want to
use that chance for you know having our
of beers bang cars you know I like why
should I use the second transform and I
think using it for serving the community
and make an impact on other people's
life was what makes it for me
you
you